we've seen signs of inflation really
peaking now but of course it's far too
high
now we think it's going to come down
sharply really from the early summer
onwards
but we haven't seen that happen yet back
at the beginning of February yeah we
were really a bit on a knife edge as to
whether there would be a recession
certainly we thought the economy would
be quite stagnant I'm not saying it's
going to it's not Off to the Races let's
be clear but I'm a bit more optimistic
people shouldn't worry that it's a
repeat of 2008. no I don't think it's a
repeat of 2008 at all yeah we have par
we've obviously increased the regulation
of the banking system since then we
learned a lot of lessons in the
financial crisis we keep learning
lessons of course we keep learning
lessons that's natural in life but I'm
confident that the banks banks in this
country are in a much stronger position
well the chancellor says that he
supports the bank's decision
Jeremy Hunt saying with Rising prices
strangling growth and eroding family
budgets the sooner we grip inflation the
better for everyone that's why we
support the bank of England's actions
today and why we will continue to play
our part in this fight by being
responsible with the public finances
alongside providing cost of living
support worth an average of 3 300 pounds
per household over this year and next